[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur anderson aurait falsifié des
notes d'examens au déploiement des noirs
[Musique]
c'est un événement majeur de notre
histoire mais peu connu pour combler ce
trou de mémoire collective
ces jeunes ont produit la pièce
black-out c'est une des raisons qu'on a
décidé de créer cette caisse le
justement c'est de dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on se rappelle pas de cet événement
qui est un événement extrêmement
marquant pas juste dans l'histoire du
québec ministre du canada
pour moi c'est important de maintenant
voir là dedans puis de rallier mes amis
francophones là dessus puis d'essayer de
vraiment partager l'amour partagé
l'histoire pour que ça sorte le plus
possible pour qu'on puisse avoir une
réconciliation il ya 50 ans un conflit à
l'université soeur jody williams
maintenant concordia mettez le feu aux
poudres de tensions raciales clarin ce
béni enseignait déjà à l'époque mais
c'est un emploi ou quels leviers
nationale qu'il avait attiré à montréal
en 1960 grâce à son doctorat en économie
des transports monsieur b né le premier
noir à la compagnie des chemins de fer a
occupé un poste autres que bagagistes ou
serveur venant de trinité et tobago
c'est à montréal qu'il découvre le
racisme tout en restant black's les
événements tragiques de sir george
williams ont été provoquées par des
difficultés c'est à dire des problèmes
des problèmes d'ordre racial qui remonte
à 1 en conviant 1
c'est le temps qu'a pris l'université
pour répondre ou plutôt ne pas répondre
aux plaintes de racisme portées par six
étudiants noirs contre un professeur de
biologie
y a personne qui est retourné pour dire
on entendu votre plainte malheureusement
vous allez voir ses preuves est de
retour c'est j'espère par hasard que
lyon a pris que 2 1 leur plainte a été
rejetée et qu'elle 2-2 le professeur
avait reçu une promotion
la colère de six étudiants fait tache
d'huile
plusieurs associations étudiantes
mobilisent leurs membres après deux
semaines des manifestations pacifiques
se transforme en est mort
200 étudiants se barricadent d'abord
dans la cafétéria
puis dans la salle des ordinateurs ou
neuvième étage le 11 février 1969
les événements se bousculent vers 7h les
occupants commencer a lancé par les
plaies de ne vienne tout ce qui leur
tombait sous la main
machine à écrire l'outillage
mécanographiques et des milliers de cap
et de rubans de lecture parfaite
l'adduction électronique
quelques heures plus tard un incendie
éclate
les occupants de l'achat d'ordinateurs
suffoque ce jour là le professeur ben
croiser des contre-manifestants de dire
bonne fête de la pièce de théâtre de la
cad se concentre sur cette souffrance
encore actuelle c'est le genre de
traumatisme qu'il faut déterrer pour
pouvoir avancer puis aller de l'avant 90
ça se transmet dans le corps c'est des
choses qui restent ancrées dans la
communauté noire
50 ans c'est une personne qui marche
dans la rue et on criait lady and bird
laisser les brûler c'est ça c'est
quelqu'un que je pourrait croiser dans
la vie
un moment de création on tombe sur slave
ça aussi on entre ici dans la pièce
parce qu'elles pourraient ils disent oui
il ya des choses qui ont changé mais dit
quand guy nantel dit j'ose espérer que
nous n'allons pas nous plier devant les
doléances des nounous parano qui voit du
racisme partout dans notre société c'est
très semblable
qu'est-ce qu'on dise aux utilisant les
50 ans qu on les policiers passent à
l'attaqué
les assiégés mettre le feu aux
barricades et en deux minutes c'est la
panique
une centaine d'étudiants sont arrêtés et
accusés d'avoir mis le feu aux
ordinateurs
ce qu'ils ont toujours nié accusant
plutôt les policiers les dommages sont
évalués à 2 millions de dollars
certains des insurgés risque la prison à
vie
c'est de ce constat et haine
les étudiants de l'université sur le
tourisme ont écrit une page d'histoire
en révélant l'ampleur d'un racisme
latent
après les émeutes de 69 il n'était plus
possible d'ignorer la discrimination
systémique subies par les noirs au
canada daté inaf il y a maintenant des
noirs partout dit le professeur qui
toujours en poste à l'université
concordia
mais ils sont encore largement sous
représentées dans les emplois supérieurs
et d'autorité les préjugés persistent
ils font encore mal je pense qu'on doit
on doit guérir de notre penseur on doit
guérir de notre crainte de l'autre on
doit guérir des préfète préconçues puis
pour en guérir fonds apparu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]